[Music]
welcome back to after record we're
talking about whatever we want
and we got anthony lee back what's the
latest crypto you bought
crypto [ __ ] don't crypto crypto
i heard you're like a total degenerate
now for a little while no dude i'm very
humble with my uh earnings
you're a degenerate hey all those uh
people out there that are like
part of his team he's a degenerate time
out define degenerate steve
time in you time
the dictionary picture i just said i i
was i introduced you to a couple of this
thing
these things like three weeks ago and
now i want to knight you as a [ __ ] dj
because you were explaining
all these dj moves to these guys and i
should so you taught me a thing or two
you are now a dj congratulations
congratulations that was the nft right
there
take a picture of the money masters
right here dude i graduated the course
yep there it is okay welcome to the
family so honored
the sword as a gift thank you to
everybody out there
he went he dude that's got the crypto
sword you guys are total geeks about
crypto
when you when you guys talk about it
you're part of this too buddy
no i'm just listening i'm i'm a part i'm
a part of i'm not obviously
born he just listens but do you know how
many people come through here
and they sit in that chair and they're
like oh my god tell me about it oh my
god yeah hook me up all this [ __ ] and
then we leave they never
they never text me nothing nothing never
reach out nothing this guy hits me up
the same night he hits me up two hours
after we're finished filming and we're
on a skype call that night and we're
[ __ ] degenning already for four hours
very proactive man also he has already
been in the crypto world for
a second right yeah it wasn't like brand
brand it was not brand new
i got into 2017 but i was one of those
dudes that like didn't really know
anything so i was like buy this and hold
it right
and it wasn't even like smart it wasn't
like buy bitcoin and ethereum and hold
it it was like buy this and i
made hell of money off ethereum and i
was like oh this works and i bought a
bunch of [ __ ] coins and i like lost all
just say you made a lot of money off
ethereum i did i did well conceptual
money right because i like never
put it back in like no no no but after
that bought a bunch of [ __ ] coins
he bought a lot of true true blue [ __ ]
cleanse too i was impressed yeah
what's some of the [ __ ] coins the
[ __ ] diversified got some doge
coins no no before doge was even a thing
i got random [ __ ]
nothing's like stuff i never even heard
of in my life why
swipe what but what what was your logic
behind these coins
well at the time um i just tried to be
at the bellagio i didn't know anything
right i didn't know anything and then i
was just like
when you turn like five thousand dollars
into like let's say like 60 grand right
probably
why why let's say 60 grand why not just
save me like 58 all right anyways
you really want to know what you're
working with
like really badly once once you see it's
like a
monday i wouldn't say like the faster
you make money the faster you spend it
yeah right not true
same well kind is for me so
so the second's like oh i got a payday
or something like that you like quickly
suddenly
are like maybe i could do this like five
times over bought a bunch of [ __ ] coins
lots of money
um and then went into like a hold period
during the crypto winter for like three
years right uh so it didn't do anything
didn't didn't do anything it was a
crypto winter oh yeah it's a cycle it's
a market cycle we were part of that
explain please
the winter is crypto winter is after the
bull market
the blow off top happened right bitcoin
hit 20 000. everyone's like holy [ __ ] i
can't lose anymore and that's when
busting all over the place
and they're like it's all over it's
never coming back it was a ponzi scheme
how about this and then no one talks
about it nobody on the media nobody
and then all my smart friends are
collecting and buying yeah and i was not
one of those smart people neither were
we
no i didn't sold i held and then this
year because i held this year
suddenly a couple things went like and i
was like
holy [ __ ] but i still didn't know what
to do in numbers what does that mean
thirsty i would say like maybe like when
after the crypto winter my like balance
went down to like
four grand oh [ __ ] yeah from 58 to four
no well when i when i was in like
2017-18 it got up to like 80.
wow that's nothing it came down to like
four and i was like did you hear me and
joe's stories
okay well yeah you guys are you got this
i went from i went from a million to 20
grand we were homeless well fine i don't
want to talk anymore about my story it's
like 26 grand to your credit
26 grand that hurts well but it wasn't
that crazy
i gotta say that but then it was fun but
you know during that time though
i was like i wish i had money right now
to buy more
and i was so pissed because i didn't
have money at that moment because i
bought everything so [ __ ] high or at
least you never sold because that's what
some people do yeah you don't realize
your losses you don't really lose
dj oh yeah oh he's been one yeah yeah i
knighted him when he
when he [ __ ] 200
oh yeah well i'm a wizard though yeah
he's like oh like wizard warlock queen
whatever
gandalf over here i'm crypto kingdom joe
was knighted on the jk party set
oh yeah but but now it's back and it's
not it's no longer winter it's like
crypto summer and [ __ ] right
at the beginning of it spring spring
there it is it's spring
i'm like rooting against the the coin
that we used to
all be in but it's actually coming up
like what the [ __ ] oh why you can't root
against these things it's gonna [ __ ] you
because because i pulled out of omg i'm
like oh yeah omg so
it's like disgruntled ex-girlfriend i
know i know
i'm a [ __ ] noob in this in this field
but i can't help but feel the way i feel
i'm like
[ __ ] it now it's at 10. i should have
pulled out now it's about when you're
pulling out though that's what matters
when you're about to pull out that's
when you should be
like in the right lane where you're like
i made the right choices until then i
made the right choice
we're all doing laps around the track
and sometimes they're ahead sometimes
you're ahead like you just have to know
why you bought what you bought that's
all
see crypto sensei right there
everybody's got to get a sensei
some people in kansas would be like how
do you know stuff i was like i got a
cryptocency
get off me dogs are you like the most
informed crypto person
in like the dance space you would say
maybe in the dance space no i don't
think
or the dancers that you know about i
wouldn't say most informal i would say
i'll probably like the deepest dj
yeah because i was kicking off some
fitness peeps and i think i don't even
know that much compared like joe and
steve
and i think i'm the deepest in there and
then i have friends that are like
maybe like eight nine figure dudes and
like what do you guys think about this
crypto
and i'm like dude you better get in it
you could buy a lot more foam he got
eight nine figures and he doesn't know
[ __ ] about crypto
just tell them to buy one bitcoin or
more it's crazy how like people's levels
of knowledge of things
you could be quadruple genius in one
area and then
and then in another area they're like
can you trust it but this is why i tell
people that they haven't missed the boat
and it's not too late almost [ __ ]
people say
it hit 60 000 this morning bitcoin 61
last night yeah
there you go but that's what i mean it's
not over some people thought it was over
at 45 000 for example
or 50 or when it was dipped after 50 it
like went back to 42 and
almost like 42 and people like holy [ __ ]
it's over now but then these people are
also not investors and they don't
understand
the psychology behind investing it's
they're very short-sighted right because
like if you've never invested before
like in stocks or anything
then you're looking at a small window of
time so like
the last bitcoin run like 2017 the huge
one right where everyone started talking
about it and it made it kind of
mainstream
that was the time when everyone was
either going hardcore or doubting it
and then when it did crash the naysayers
were like confirmed like see
i told you but it's like you could say
that about any stock
yeah everything is the same there's just
like
that's the whole point right it's now at
sixty thousand it was last march of
three thousand
you didn't miss it yet because there
will be another cycle where you have
another opportunity you'll never get a
three thousand again i promise you that
right now
but you know will you can you get it
maybe at twenty eight thousand thirty
thousand there's this new brazilian
strain
maybe if we get more strains coming out
and when the world gets shut down oh
that got all loose there you go
[Laughter]
pray for a worse pandemic yeah maybe we
yeah we give we get three thousand
dollar bitcoin
to go back on that question of like um
in like my own how much money you have
no am i like one of the people who's
like most into it i realize that when i
when i end up trying to explain crypto
to people who uh
kind of like aren't super into investing
or don't have like familiar they need a
foundation of investing first it's not
even just a foundation of investing it's
like a foundation of like the
philosophy behind cryptocurrency there's
like a baseline
yeah and a belief because investing is a
very emotional game to be completely
understanding of economics too exactly
it's like it's like
the second people are like oh why are
you into this it's not so easy for me to
just be like because this is going to
double in money because like that
doesn't really like
that's what the average person is
looking at that's the surface level [ __ ]
it's kind of like you have to go into
this like
well we're in kind of like a financial
revolution of social economic reform
and like over time this is gonna you
know what i'm saying so it's kind of
like
you have to give a foundation of belief
for you to have the emotional capacity
to even be willing to invest in
something you don't fully understand
gamestop was not an accident right what
happened with gamestop was a watershed
moment that
indicated to the rest of our country
really and the world
that people aren't going to take this
[ __ ] anymore where wall street can over
leverage
but then if people make money on
gamestop the system is going to snap
back on the people
or financial institutions get bailed out
all the time
but not individuals not individuals all
that stuff builds up over the years
guess what causes layers and layers of
resentment and then when gamestop
happens
you the all these people on tv are going
this is bad
and everyone in the streets is going
[ __ ] you and then crypto is our only
tool our only weapon
to actually fight back against these
power structures and the irs is trying
to
they're going to try to tax the [ __ ] out
of the people making money on crypto
like hardcore that's why you gotta
report normally
unfairly hardcore yeah so you matter
what report your taxes
don't let them beat you or move to
certain locations go to puerto rico
that's the best one i heard it's zero
zero zero zero yeah you might be like
missing a couple of regular things that
you normally associate with your life
you have to pronounce your voting rights
because i'm like sure yeah
[Laughter]
check it out baby today's video is
brought to you by gabby
insurance do you know what this means
the gabi
is get a better insurance because that's
exactly what they do
you go on there and you're like hmm i
wonder if i really got the best car
insurance or home insurance let me do a
double check
and then you type it in and for the same
coverage
that you have right now they're gonna
compare apples to apples and see if they
can get you a better rate in most cases
they do
and that's because they have over 40
different insurance companies that they
compare to
and um you know with major guys like
nationwide progressive and all them
they really look for the best rates for
you
and this is how i know i'm getting old
because i was up on there looking for
home insurance because you know my house
in vegas
and i'm like what kind of young man
looks at home insurance
and no young man does that but
what made the old man and me happy is i
was able to save 60 bucks
a month on insurance wow yeah because
you're they're comparing apples to
apples and you know sometimes some
insurance companies
they favor one thing over the other so
they're able to
take my entire house put it inside where
the location is
and they figure out what the best
insurance rate was and i was able to
save 70 bucks and for me
moving to vegas is all about saving
money yeah that just helps out it's
right in line with what i'm trying to do
that's sixty dollars every month you
could be using on the craps tables yup
seven hundred and twenty dollars a year
yeah that's
69.99 prime rib dinners that you could
be getting
like six of them from 2am to 4am yup
that's
six lap dances that you could do when
they are on a half special deal only if
jio's asleep that i could say
yeah but if you if you're looking to
save some money on some home insurance
because you're old man like me
or some car insurance go to gabby.com
off the record your oh
you owe it to yourself to check it
because it's completely free you can
compare
all the insurance companies out there
that's gabby.com off the record
hey guys today's video is brought to you
by green
chef green chef maybe the first usda
certified organic
meal kit sent to your house and you know
why i love these guys
so taika's been really getting into
cooking he really he sees me and jio
cook and he like
goes oh cool i want to cook with you
guys and what's cool about green chef
it's everything
is already pre-prepared pre-measured so
instead of like taking things and made
it becoming a big old mess and i have to
watch taika like throw a potato in the
trash can
or throw a carrot across the room it's
exactly what we see is what we need in
front of us so i go
taku can you crack that one egg put it
over here can you chop that one carrot
and he's really involved so it's just a
really fun
family activity i know a lot of people
like to play board games but cooking
together and then also enjoying what you
ate right after
is a really cool bonding experience and
what i like about it
is they have super delicious meals that
are keto friendly
like some of them are only 14 net carbs
in the whole thing that's really good
and before i would get like meal preps
or whatever and it's convenient but it's
not fresh it's not delicious it's not
like
uh this is way better especially if you
get it on a sunday and you got to eat it
on thursday you're like
why does this vegetable smell like that
meat
because it's been sitting there the
whole time and it looks old yeah but
with this you get fresh ingredients
and they are the most sustainable meal
kit
packet out there right now so make sure
you go to greenchef.com
90 off the record i don't know why
because you get 90 off
plus free shipping if you go right now
so if you're looking for delicious meal
or just something
fun to do with your family and cook
together go to greenchef.com90
off the record for 90 off plus free
shipping
that's a lot of money yep bye-bye see
you laters go cook something
yummy yummy what people want to do is
they're like hey
if i put a thousand dollars in here am i
going to make 2
000 that's all they want to know like
but then in order for you
to get into investing responsibly you
have to know that
this can be zero at any given time even
if it's
quote unquote for sure like even stocks
are the same [ __ ] right
but then if you can't stomach that it is
a mental game or an emotional game if
you can't stomach it don't [ __ ] play
you got a stomach that your wife could
leave you yeah that's how much you got
to stomach
those are all the funny memes those are
like
i put 50 grand on gamestop my wife left
me
that's i didn't tell her
that's the best the best is i didn't
tell her i said we only i said we only
put in 2 000
and then they show the balance and it
says negative like 48 000
that is where the deceit comes and
that's why he got but that's how legends
are born
i know that's hilarious that's why he
was left wifeless that's
what hollywood films are made of you
know what i'm saying yeah man i'm trying
to be a legendary
born in the fire bro they're not born in
the cold
i actually think by being too um
into like this revolutionary thing
emotionally
is actually working against you like the
diamond handed people of gamestop
like they they they're like we need to
fight against the system and then they
put millions of dollars
or they could have pulled out but
they're like we're gonna fight against
it and then like they're just sitting
there holding bags
meaning like depending on who they are
and depending on how they played it
because they're
the the what's really going on behind
the scenes right that's what i'm always
asking what's going on behind the scenes
why did this happen well if they cashed
out i think it's fine but then like
there are people that didn't and they're
left with bags because there's always
winners and losers
in investing in things like this yes of
course yeah but with
gamestop for example i bought gamestop
and i'm never selling it
i'm literally never gonna did you wipe
your bank account no no no
yeah yeah but if that's what i mean by
it's a movement no you should not
over leverage yourself to be part of the
exactly but but i bought a ticket to the
show
why are you never selling gamestop
because it's a [ __ ] you to the hedge
funds to the hedges but it's a
reasonable amount right like 50 bucks
but there are people who dedicate and
devout themselves so emotionally to this
movement that they'll wipe out their
whole bank account
to be a soldier in it well it's a
gambling addict though yeah and they're
legends too yeah
well if that's what they're about i
think that's cool that they're you know
walking the walk that's right that's
what i'm saying is it but it does
do them a disservice or like it's like
at the end of the day
you're like this quote unquote hero to
yourself right and you might be
like feeling all proud about it but it's
like
did it really help you though as an
investor no you were more like
a hero like you're not an investor
you're just doing it for pride
yeah just don't don't go too hard is all
yeah yeah basically or go hella hard but
i do
i think i think it's honorable they're
money like it's like well i go hard
right but like
we're like but i'm not doing it that's
what i'm thinking the
yeah but then but then i'm not sitting
here with a sword hey don't go too hard
dude your eyes won't be you're not this
way wait you're not listening to what
i'm saying
i'm not saying just do it for like
because you believe in something i'm
doing it as an investor and i know what
i'm getting myself
no but then it wasn't the conversation
also that in order to be an investor and
a smart investor you have to be able to
believe
in what you're investing as well i think
there's a spectrum because to me it's
like starving artists right
like who says the starving artist that
thinks he's doing super pure [ __ ]
isn't successful he might be to him to
him he might be that's ultimate
happiness that's ultimate
thank you so for so for me i'm like if
that's you
go ahead if you want to have to like
[ __ ] find half a hot dog in a trash
can
and go paint something that's awesome
but then there's also
there's there's like the commercial
artists right that want to make
blockbuster movies and there's anyone in
between
and i feel like even with investors the
same thing there's people that fully
believe in the movement if they're a
hero to themselves and that's what makes
them happy
go ahead and do that but if you want to
be a true investor like what joe's
saying
then the ultimate is your roi well if
your roi sucks or just a shitty
exactly there's rules too the word the
phrase that we've all used
never invest more than you're willing to
lose applies to your stupid movement
yeah
right never means never don't invest
more than you're willing to lose that's
absolutely a fact
that's so if you put in like 50 bucks
and you can lose it
right now this is just going based off
of the first statement that you made
about like going in
and you have to believe what you're
doing right and a lot of people they'll
just like throw money at it because
someone told them that they're going to
make money into it
and it makes sense but then my whole
point is that when you believe too much
and you devout yourself
like without thinking that's when you
get into deep [ __ ] that's when you
become an extremist
exactly and people don't talk to you
really
yeah except for other extremists and
then you get yourself into like a
[ __ ] echo chamber
yeah that's why i hang out here what's
crazy though what's super ironic is uh
all the people in high school that like
paid attention to like finance
economics and accounting that i used to
call a lot of really bad names in my own
mind when i see them
your own mind why did i pay attention to
this [ __ ]
because i under the understand this [ __ ]
at a much bigger level i'm like you
[ __ ] i can't even say these words
anymore
that's a funny thing too like when
you're a kid you think the cool [ __ ]
is is what matters but yeah oh
[ __ ] is what matters for the rest of
your life because it's only like what 18
years of your life that you're trying to
be cool and it's
not even helping you for the rest of
your [ __ ] i don't know seven years
you care about reputation from people
that aren't even gonna matter
yeah and then you're like my reputation
is at stake and it's like you're in
ninth grade what [ __ ] reputation do
you have and you only got to be cool for
four years
max and then once you're out you're the
lame kid who left high school and no
one's talking about you
i've never got good grades and i [ __ ]
always sag
their their pants or their [ __ ]
backpack and they have scoliosis and
[ __ ]
remember that pass i threw though at
that one game that pass was pretty sick
living in the fashion constantly like
yeah my my [ __ ]
the good old days and they're just
reliving their high school
do you think people are still talking
about them like till this day do you
think
there's people that that are talking
about the cool
people in high school like remember that
guy when he said that [ __ ] to the
teacher
or like remember how he used to know his
past
right maybe if that was your heyday
that's so
sad dude that guy told a legendary joke
in math man
it never happened that never happens
yeah or i guess even the other way
around where like people
right now in our 30s are we talking
about a kid
from high school that had an
embarrassing moment only when they shift
themselves and stuff
yeah did you definitely start talking
about yeah if you [ __ ] [ __ ] yourself
for the most part like obviously the
extreme ones aren't gonna stick with you
but you know as
when you're a teenager you think like
any tiny little thing like oh my god i
went out
and i had a booger in my nose and i
didn't even notice and then it's like
[ __ ] detrimental for them it's like
no one's gonna remember that but i tell
a story to this day about a girl
on the first day of high school got [ __ ]
on by a bird
going into first period that never gets
old though like you can't
i will never unlive that visual and
that's your first day of high school
it's the most nervous day and
all over her new clothes and head yeah
all over it was a splatter
and it was like four birds kind of
attacked one girl
they hated what she was wearing so
that's what i mean if you want to stand
out [ __ ] yourself or get [ __ ] on by
something or
you know that'll that helps yeah and now
that girl has a great personality
that girl's killing it's crypto most
people i know that have like lives that
like each year progress a little bit i
don't even hear them talking about
things that
happened like five years ago really you
know they're so they're so like in the
now and they're just crushing it it's
like they're just
they just keep talking about what's
going on to be fair though i would like
to
assume that people in this room are like
forward thinking and like constantly on
some type of hustle but that's like not
super common you think everyone is
shitty and dumb and lazy
i don't think everyone is i disagree
with you i think they're hella pods of
people
they're hella positive people that like
have a very very amazing and content
lifestyle for themselves that doesn't
need to be like
hyper progressive or like always
constantly forwarding because in there
now it's like chill
yeah you know what i mean so when you're
kind of like i'm one of those people i'm
chilling
you're a little bit well you're not
doing nothing you're not doing nothing
yeah you're pretty progressive i mean
now i've just kind of like taken a
backseat
for the most part so i'm like i'm one of
those people nah
if you look at your trajectory like
let's say a 10 year window right what is
it 21
2011 or 2021 it's for sure [ __ ]
exponential you're like cardano right
now dude you're like
ada still consistent you know what i'm
saying maybe 2019 to 2021 it's like
linear oh that's everyone though yeah
but i mean that's
that's just yeah it's just like that
it's a little bump it's a little bump
two years there's nothing yeah you gotta
zoom out when in doubt zoom out yeah
you also gotta look back give yourself
some [ __ ] credit too because like you
know you've done a lot of cool things
yeah oh thank you i was not trying to
fish for compliments but thank you
let's keep going when you first came
into this organization
remember honey didn't speak english look
how great your english is now oh my god
for real
remember when you came here from mexico
and you were just
looking for a job and you found yourself
here and you had yellow fever and you're
like
which one of these [ __ ] is
going down with oh god
imagine that was my actual story no way
it's not far off
your actual story for me the whole time
until i i started to get to know you i
was like oh [ __ ] casey likes armenian
chicks
i can see it i can't joe over there was
like man
likes cross-eyed girls for some reason
you thought
i thought she was cross-eyed the first
time for the first year that i met her
and i was like oh [ __ ] i can't stare i
can't stare don't look into her eyes
we used to work here oh yeah how do you
get
you didn't even confirm it by looking
for like three seconds where are your
glasses did they go like this oh i
didn't have
jet glasses and you know like people's
eyes look crazy with glasses
yeah and i had braces too so you're like
damn casey's into the
[ __ ] no because we have we look at
your chart dude yeah blow up
we used to work here from like a nine to
f remember you remember right like nine
to five style
and then so like tiff would come in
maybe like 30 minutes or an hour before
everyone got off to wait for casey
and then every time i walk by the door
i'm like oh casey likes romanian chicks
this time
he was also living in an area that was
predominantly armenian so maybe that's
why oh yeah
glendale yeah glendale that's right
[Music]
you